Holotalk and Profiles in Holography is brought to you through the generous support of the International Holography Fund.
For more information, visit their website at holographyfund.org.
Hi, Frank.
Hi, Jonathan, how are you?
Yeah, not too bad, thank you.
Yourself.
I'm glad to have you on the show.
Great, thank you.
And it has a wide listener audience.
Okay.
And let me just let the listeners know that we're speaking to Jonathan Cope, and you are in what town in England?
Are you in London?
I'm on the outskirts of London.
The outskirts of London.
Okay.
Now, you're a graduate from RCA, right?
It's true.
And maybe I uh let me clarify that for the listeners as well, so I don't have someone writing to me and saying, My grandfather worked for RCA back in the fifties.
Right.
Because RCA is actually a company here.
At Royal College of Art.
Uh-huh.
Why don't you start off by telling the listeners a little bit about how you got involved with holography in the first place?
Oh boy, how long do we have?
Probably not long enough.
But suffice to say, um I guess I've always been interested in anything unusual, um, be it uh visual or or sonic.
Um so uh I guess that kind of what drew me in.
Um seeing holograms uh from an early age.
I was lucky enough to be born and raised in uh the center of England in Eric called Loughborough in Leicestershire.
Okay.
Uh and that's where a lot of the early pioneering work was done by people like Nick Phillips uh at the Loughborough University.
Uh and I'm sure I would have been a case of uh seeing some uh exhibits, probably aged about ten, so in the the mid seventies.
Uh you you can do the math.
Okay.
Um and just uh being really wowed by uh this ability to um you know view a three dimensional image held within a two dimensional plane um and something that for me felt always lacking in conventional art um was that you know we we live and inhabit a three dimensional world so you know why does art have to be uh constrained to two dimensions uh and so I guess that that really kind of made an impact on on me at an early age.
So you you developed a very intellectual outlook toward holography very early on in life I would say.
It seems so yeah.
Yeah.
I mean most kids that are ten years old will see a hologram and go, Oh that's cool, that's cool.
But you actually had something be some thought behind it.
Uh I guess uh yeah all the way through school I'd had a bit of an artistic inclination.
Um it's a good thing this interview isn't with some of my old teachers because that's uh probably a classic daydreamer and spent the whole time staring out the school window not really learning anything but I guess um some of us learn in different ways.
Um so I've always been a very visual oriented person.
Um so I guess that kind of what switched me on about about holograms.
Did you set up a small lab of your own or didn't you get involved with holography until you attended RCA?
Um I got involved in holography uh I um let's see now.
So long ago it's kind of uh thrown my mind back to the dates.
Must be late eighties, uh so around eighty eighty nine.
Uh no way back before that in fact well I'm older than I thought.
Uh must be eighty four uh I attended um what uh is over here uh uh a BA in arts, a bachelor of arts.
Uh I'm afraid I don't know what the equivalent would be for you guys over stateside.
But it was a four year um degree course in graphic design.
And at that time I had quite a strong leaning towards computer graphics.
Um but towards the end of the course kind of revived my interest in holography and managed to find a few courses that were being run by external sources like uh Richmond holographic studios who are quite famous in that field.
Um and managed to train with them and and started to actually get some hands on in holographic equipment, which I'm sure also many of your listeners will be aware is pretty hard to and expensive to get hold of even now.
What were some of the uh Richmond holographics work that you got involved with?
Any particular pieces?
It was it was not their work per se, it was the fact that they were running uh courses for the general public.
Uh so it was uh it was an easy way uh to actually go in and get uh hands on equipment in uh uh you know, hands on the holographic equipment for a fair price and be taught the sort of basics.
Um and then bringing that back into my graphic design course to to sort of show them and it was very difficult because it was all new to them so they didn't really have any way to rate it.
Um any way to kind of appraise it.
So I actually almost flunked that course because of that.
They they kind of just didn't know w what holography was or how it could be used.
Um but I was lucky to to get through um that that graphic design course and with a uh with a pass and then was very lucky to be accepted at the Royal College of Art.
Is that program still there at RCA?
Unfortunately no.
No, I don't want to sound ignorant by not knowing that already.
No, no, no, I'm not gonna do that.
I think I remember I heard that it uh no longer in place.
Yeah, it's a real shame.
Uh uh to my knowledge i it uh kind of died out um about um some time around ninety nine.
Are there any degreed programs in England now?
I don't know of any.
No.
I'm not aware of any in the States here either.
Yeah, I just think it was one of those uh it's it's gonna be down to econom economics more than anything.
Uh I guess, you know, that it's gonna be a niche market, there's not that many people within the art world uh who are interested in using holography.
Why is that?
Uh, you know, that's a really good question.
I I think it's one of those complex things we could we can break down into kind of public awareness.
Um for my short time in in the sphere of holography it seems to be one of those things that um goes through kind of peaks and troughs in terms of its trend.
Um you know it's kind of really popularized um maybe by I don't know sci fi or something like that or by a big exhibition being put out by by a company and sort of the public awareness of it raises it a little while and people get excited about it.
So I'm not sure if I find that as well, yeah.
Yeah.
And then and then that sort of seems to peter out again 'cause people you know think I I ultimately I guess it it's still for many people's minds constrained to that of gimmick um rather than being taken seriously.
Certainly that's the response that um we found within the sort of main artistic community the kind of fine artists kind of think it's because it's so technical there's so many uh chemicals involved and optical equipment and it's pretty difficult.
Um that does put a constraint on creativity.
It's kinda hard to find workarounds to to be creative with it.
Um which is obviously but yet there's so many beautiful artistic holograms have been created over the years.
Yeah well I think that really is the skill of of those people involved.
I think to get really creative um and and produce uh in a a work of art which will stand alongside a kind of conventional work of art I think is really quite an achievement.
Um now some of your work you've worked with pulse holography as well I know I've seen a few of your hologram is that you that's in the pulse holograms that I've seen I think the Jonathan Ross collection.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
Um just the simple expedient being that uh it's cheaper um uh you know, attending the Royal College of Art was a real dream come true, it was really fantastic, but um the bottom line is uh you start being involved in holography and I'm sure many of your listeners be aware it gets pretty expensive part of the time.
Um you know the holographic films and the chemicals involved uh don't come cheap.
Uh and then I certainly didn't have time and and money to spend on bringing in uh external models, you know, using professional people um that way so it's easiest just to kind of jump to the side of the plate and press the button with myself as a subject matter.
Yeah.
I couldn't do that because I wouldn't be a very interesting subject matter.
But you look good in the holograms.
I couldn't possibly comment on that.
I mean uh I I think as well is as much to do with um kind of the the sort of true vein of fine art actually it being a a self exploratory process.
Um you know I was trying to depict something of who I was, where I'm coming from, where I was going to um I mean there's a there's a piece um called Icarus which uh draws on on that ancient story.
Yeah it's gorgeous.
I'm sorry.
It's gorgeous.
Thank you.
Uh that was kind of the idea of of trying to get a sense of of feathers, you know so to follow on the story of of Icarus who didn't listen to his father and tried to float too close to the the sun.
So I guess that's all about not listening to kind of authority figures, which is definitely uh me I use a picture of that on the website for the radio broadcast.
Please do.
Okay.
I I I would be very pleased to do you have a website for your work or do you usually send people to Jonathan Ross collection or you know I know you have a music website, musical instruments.
That's true, yeah.
Um that that's kind of uh what I'm doing nowadays which is very interesting.
Uh but it's a whole um different world.
Um I still keep a lot of photographs uh of my art and I and I've still got all the master holograms and and many copies.
And you're offering some for sale.
Uh you might want to let listeners know that as well and where they can get them from.
Do you still have a page at eBay?
It's true, yeah.
Um searching under the name uh the seller name Johnny Cope, uh J O N N Y C O P E hopefully would um or just under the the title of holograms because there are not many people selling art holography on eBay or anywhere else for that matter.
Um it was a kind of difficult decision for me, but I've got a couple of pieces that I'll always keep in my collection because they're they're important and dear to me.
Um but ultimately I don't have room to display them and uh I think it'd better they find homes elsewhere.
I have one of your holograms.
Oh, great.
Uh it's one of the uh pulsed reductions.
Uh yeah.
Who is in the hologram?
Who is the model for that?
Can you remind me, Frank, which which one that is?
Uh it's uh just a single woman that's on an eight by ten plate.
Okay.
And it's a pulsed reduction.
And I don't nothing uh you know, I don't want to say anything badly about the woman, but I don't I can't remember anything remarkable about it to to say.
Two eyes, nose, a mouth.
Uh-huh.
Okay, sure.
Um I think from memory that was one of the series towards the end of my time at the Royal College of Art.
Uh and that was just really starting to experiment um with that technique of of um reduction holography.
Yeah, that's the only piece I've ha I have of a pulsed reduction.
Uh huh.
And only the second one that I've ever seen in my life.
Oh, okay.
Well, um, you know, there are quite a lot of uh accomplished artists out there using it very successfully.
Uh it's not too difficult technique once you've created a master hologram, in this case uh a pulsed laser, so you know, you actually got the opportunity to record uh a a living person.
Um which is great experience.
Then just simply in the transfer process, uh putting uh a large um uh uh uh convex lens, big glass lens between the master plate and the transfer plate allows it uh this optical reduction to take place.
There are a number of of workarounds that that have to be found to to make it actually happen.
Um but um it's certainly an interesting process and and is equivalent then to you know kind of photographic negative and that you can make the the final r resulting image less than life size.
Um which is cheaper for for one thing.
You have an exhibit coming up at the Jonathan Ross Gallery too, is that correct?
Uh if I do that's news to me.
Oh okay.
I thought I read something about that.
I Jonathan Ross sent me an email about uh the program that's coming up for holography in the modern museum.
And in that email he had mentioned also that I believe uh I think Amy Rush was coming up.
Uh and uh Jonathan Cope.
Okay, uh yes that that uh that does remind me.
Um to my knowledge it's not going to be an exhibit of of pieces.
It's um I've been invited to take part in a symposium which is going to be happening uh back actually in the in my home area of Leicestershire at the De Montfort um school.
Okay.
Um and Jonathan uh you know is uh I'm sure you're aware really very instrumental on keeping holography kind of out there in in the art world and just in kind of mainstream and does very a lot of great work like this to to put on these these talks and symposia.
And this one is very interesting one.
He's approaching um uh mainstream museums and asking them uh you know how and where could they use holography uh or would they feel it applicable to use and I guess he invited me because I've got um some interest and some experience in in both spheres and I'd been an art holographone I would also actually after leaving laser holograms where I worked for many years I uh I've done six years at the British Museum uh so product development manager.
Oh okay yeah I remember reading about that story.
So uh the idea is I just presented quite a simple paper about um what what holography could offer to museums uh to make it work for them I guess I may be sending a hologram over for that.
I'm working with students next week in Florida.
Okay.
And uh we're doing holograms of requ recovered artifacts from a sunken civil war ship.
Hey great.
And uh if we get good results with the the thirty by forty centimeter plates and we're probably going to send one over.
Okay.
Yeah just so it can be exhibited Frank.
This is uh your single beam reflection holograms.
Okay.
Yeah.
Easiest thing to do when you have a room full of students.
Sure.
Yeah.
Yeah still uh yeah some of my first holograms were were deny six as we called them then.
They're beautiful if you if they're done properly.
Yeah absolutely and especially on the newer emulsions where you get a higher diffraction efficiency as well.
Uh-huh yeah yeah excellent can I ask what emotions you're using nowadays because that was always the problem there there's so few uh choices.
Yeah we're using a Slavic emulsions.
Ah yeah okay and then we have I think a a box of uh the BB plates I think an eight by ten box.
Right.
But mostly we'll be doing thirty by forty centimeter.
Excellent.
Thank you.
Great.
What was your biggest frustration with holography?
Can you think of what it was that just drove you nuts and you just couldn't get past it in the creative process working with it.
Um I think uh the putting the quite large financial issues aside because um you know to to uh go back to the subject we were just talking about with emotions, there were so few back then and and even less now, so few producers of this very specialized emulsion.
Um and and it is such a specialized process that um by its nature it was very expensive material.
Certainly when you start to get up into larger, you know, the sort of thirty by forty, fifty by sixty in case of film uh sizes, it really becomes quite prohibitive for many people.
But that that aside, I think it was just uh the lack of colour.
That's why I really got interested in those those latter pieces, uh that trip dick who talked about one of the pieces, Icarus uh and Solace, um, were really all about uh trying to get uh the pseudo colour technique so actually getting some semblance of of more natural colour happening in there.
And I think that's one of the things for me holography by its nature it's de facto process uh gives a very, very pure light.
Uh it can be very bright colours, kind of uh prismatic rainbow colours, which is very appealing.
Um but I think the fact that uh for example in a in a tick typical uh hologram portrait, it's you know, uh monocolor, you know, it's green or yellow.
Yes.
Um and obviously, you know, uh that's not true to life.
So is is that frustration which I think is being worked around now and seeing some really amazing work coming through from um the former east Eastern Bloc and and Russia with that Slavic uh material you just mentioned.
I think we're getting closer and closer to full colour holography for everyone.
Yeah.
We're not that far away.
At least we weren't we're not as far away as we were e even five years ago.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, so uh that's coming.
Yeah, I think that you know, although it's uh in a way almost been pushed underground further in the uh you know, fewer people making this material, the the the people that are making it are very specialized and they really put a lot of research into it.
Um and also that some of the technology is is freeing up a little bit in that um some lasers are actually uh now we're getting in moving into solid solid state technology rather than gas lasers, which were big and clumsy and needed cooling and were very, very expensive.
Now it's it's reasonably easy to to buy these solid state lasers that are powerful enough to make a reasonable size hologram quite cheaply.
You know, it it I think that the sort of an idea of a home holo lab takes a whole jump closer with with the combination of these technologies.
Yeah.
And that's pretty exciting.
Uh I I can carry a thirty five milliwatt red laser around in my shirt pocket now.
There you go.
Is there anything that we didn't cover that you'd want to cover?
'Cause I am keeping my eye on the clock and I know you said you had to run out to pick up the little ones.
That's fine.
I I'm okay for about a good ten ten, fifty minutes yet.
Oh good.
I I really don't know um where you'd like to to go what would be of interest.
I mean um certainly in kind of my hologram career this in my time working for the hologram companies, um did quite a long time with Light Fantastic Gallery.
So you did some commercial work in holography as well.
What were your responsibilities doing that?
Um well, um starting back uh in my colleges when I was doing my four year graphic design course, um it was it was unusual uh its time in that we were encouraged to spend quite a lot of time out in the in industry actually as a way to learn.
It wasn't just all based at uh a university or a college.
Um and so I kind of scattered around for work and was lucky enough to learn some some work at uh what was then um Light Fantastic, uh who were one of the first c commercial hologram com companies in the UK.
Yes.
Um and worked their way up and ended up having quite a large uh display hologram gallery in an area called the Trocadero in central London uh and a shop uh and I was bought in to create um holographic products.
Um so drawing on my my background of graphic design I could come up with concepts which um allowed holog holography to be used as a vehicle to actually you know provide giftware for people.
The easy thing being you know a hologram of an object and then it's just put in a frame and sold as kind of small art with that extra dimension.
But also as well kind of trying to be more creative with it and coming up with um giftware that that used holography in a new and in and interesting way.
And that was really great opportunity.
And what did you come up with?
A lot of it was um one of the the best projects I I I did which I really enjoyed uh and um was lucky enough for it to be proved really quite successful was um one of my other great interests is in um ancient artifacts and and ancient history particularly as we've got such a rich um culture of that here in the UK.
Um and in the centre of England uh area called York there was an archaeological discovery um which was found to be uh an early Viking settlement um which is the precursor of of what is now York and it was called uh Yorvik and as the Yorvick centre was created for that.
And they had a number of um Viking artifacts which we made holograms of and incorporated incorporated them into giftware.
So for example one of the pieces was um some Viking artifacts which we made into hologram and then I had it um cut so it's uh basically a jigsaw and the idea then then that's put into a bag and uh it's sold to children as a kind of archaeological find that you can't tell what it is.
Uh it's in a kind of bag which is pretending to be an archaeological finds bag with a little tag attached to it um with a find number in the way that in archaeologists would tag this information.
Um and the child has to take it home and reassemble it to actually unlock what what image is there and actually things in three D which is was great fun and a number of other products as well.
Did they sell that at the British Museum gift shop?
I certainly hope they would.
Um that would have been ideal but actually was specifically for this quite a large museum which still exists in York, this Yorvick Center.
Um so they were particular to to that um that venue.
You know I have a lot of towns around me that I originally the names I imagine were from England.
'Cause York is two hours from me here in Pennsylvania.
Reading?
Reading is another town in England, right?
Reading is about an hour and a half.
Uh-huh.
So we're just filled with uh English named towns here in Pennsylvania.
There we go, the founder father's wondering.
What's your future plans for holography?
Uh I know you haven't been doing holography lately, is that true?
But do you plan on getting involved with it again or have it as a memory.
Uh it's a great memory.
Um it's uh I I try to live life without any regrets.
I mean I I I lead a pretty full and busy life now.
I'm also uh father of two children which is great and that that kind of takes up a chunk of time.
Uh and I run my own business with this this um selling of uh rare and unusual musical instruments which is something I I really enjoy.
I think if I had enough time, um which you know who of us can say that we have enough time in our lives through all our interests um I I'd certainly would love to if I had the space and the time and perhaps a little bit of spare money I w I would love to have a hologram studio here again uh in my home, especially what we've said about the the emergent technology with solid state lasers and so on and forth.
Maybe it's something to think about as I get a bit older and maybe retire, uh something that might resurface.
Yeah.
Um I was asked yesterday I I actually went to a museum yesterday and my wife and I went up to the ticket counter and I asked for two tickets and a woman looked at me and she asked me senior citizen?
Oh dear That was the first time that happened to me in in my life yesterday.
And I realized it's gotta happen sooner or later but I wish it would have happened later than yesterday.
Right.
So I was asked yesterday if I was a senior citizen.
Well but my hair's all turned white and everything now, you know and I just don't know.
Yeah.
But you know you still have a lot of good years left with you.
I mean there are there are labs in England where I guess where you could rent time if you could get contracts for holograms, right?
Sure, yeah.
I mean I've really enjoyed my time in holography.
I mean uh from this early work at Light Fantastic and then directly after um uh graduating from the Royal College of Art I started up my own business called 3D vision um and did a number of large scale holograms for for companies in the UK and that was great and then went off to work at Laser Holograms who ended up being one of the largest producers of film holograms in Europe uh was there for many years.
Um and and that was all fantastic.
Uh I think it was only just some differences of opinions with my then business partners led to me leaving that business and actually going off and working at the British Museum and that was kind of the end of my uh hologram career if you like and from then it's really been put on hold.
Um if I had the time to to get back into it I I certainly would but at this point um my own involvement is is keeping uh this um collection of holograms that I've got both of my own work and other people's but that now reluctant reluctantly I've decided to sell a few of Yeah.
What is the world of holography like in England in today's march no uh for for most general people it probably doesn't exist.
It's not on their radar at all.
Um if you ask the average person in the street I I think they would probably scratch their head and think long and hard and maybe make the realization that ah yes we've got holograms, security holograms on our bank notes currently um or possibly those on their credit card.
But otherwise I think in terms of display holography, art holography it probably just doesn't feature.
Uh sadly, i i it sort of seems to be an uncomfortable fit with the art world.
The general art community don't really carry a great deal of respect for it because there's not many people working in it or it's difficult to find access to for the reasons of the equipment and the expense and so on so forth.
Uh those those are horrible reasons to reject something.
It's really tough and and maybe that will start to give now um you know if it's gonna start to get more accessible.
Um I think it needs to move beyond this this um uh being seen as a gimmick by the gener general public.
You know it's uh there's not many people that you could take into a hologram exhibit that wouldn't go wow you know or be amazed by a hologram but then uh you know, are they gonna remember that two weeks later or are they gonna want to see it regularly?
Um it's an interesting interesting point.
I just I d I don't fully understand the reasons behind it but for some reason it's not just really permeated through into this kind of general culture.
Um for me that's probably down to the issue of colour again.
You know, my first time of seeing a real full colour hologram was really beyond wow.
Uh you know, to see something in three D in in monocolor, even the post portrait is really quite standing to actually look at someone's face in that detail in 3D, but to have it in natural colour really is is something else.
Yeah.
Do you think that it being associated so much with science fiction has been a stigma to it in the art world?
It's like all the Star Trek people and everything are always talking about holograms being you know projected and you know all this and that.
Does that turn a number of artists off because it's so strongly associated with science fiction rather than I'm sure you could be really onto something there.
I think also as well that probably explains uh for some people uh that exposure to a real hologram for most gener of of the general public might also be conversely rather than the wow it might be a bit of a disappointment because it was so used to even from an early age I mean I'm speaking from a a generation which remembers watching uh the original Star Wars uh and the Princess the famous Princess Leia projection hologram.
Um and it's been used in so many other things like uh the ho the idea of the holodeck and this immersive um in Star Trek.
Yeah.
Uh that's a shame because there's so many other technologies that have been embraced.
Yeah maybe holography I mean I I've always been of the the opinion I'm I'm sure this has been said by many but holography is is an applic sorry is a science waiting for an application.
It's kind of a still a little bit before its time.
Um so I'm hoping it's gonna roll down again and get another chance uh to be taken more seriously.
Okay.
Well we're coming up on thirty minutes, Jonathan.
So um Yeah I probably need to think about uh heading off to pick up my phone.
Well I want to thank you for taking the time.
I know you've got a very busy schedule and it's a busy day for you.
It's uh nice to to kind of reminisce and think back.
I mean it's not so long ago I'm not so old but still like an age ago sometimes I'll have this up for February first and all the whole took listeners will come on.
Then it'll be archived at Profiles in holography.
Okay.
Which is a site that has been funded by the International Holography Fund.
Excellent.
And we thank them for that.
Yeah, I thank you again.
And Jonathan, it was great to talk to you.
And good luck with the conference.
Yeah, thank you.
I'll be thinking about you.
Um I hold the thought that one day I'll be involved in holography again.
Okay, great.
All right.
Talk to you later.
Cheers now.
Bye.